3000 euro wenig bieten ich habe das
direkte lesen und ich dachte so alter
wald vor allem ich habe tausend euro
verhandlungs basis angegeben und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja dadurch hoffen natürlich euch jetzt
gut erstmal muss ich sagen tut mir leid
dass jetzt länger hier auf dem kanal
nichts kam
ich hatte nicht so die besten ideen und
da wollte ich auch nicht irgendeinen
müll hochladen weil ich habe jetzt an
sich so meist sonne erreicht den ich
unbedingt erreichen wollte und jetzt
versuche ich bisher in sachen zu machen
auf die ja auch wirklich nur richtig
bock hat weiß man das verstehen können
aber es kommt trotzdem weiterhin sehr
viele videos also auf jeden fall mehr
als jetzt in der letzten woche heute
habe ich nämlich was super interessantes
vor was mir wird sehr lang nachgehalten
ich habe damals 100.000 abonnenten play
button zerstört vielleicht jemand ganz
kurzer ausschnitt wie dumm das
eigentlich war
das ist gerade echt ein trauriger moment
für mich okay ich will gar nicht mach
die augen zu ok und ich habe in diesem
video schon gesagt aber es ist ja nicht
so schlimm
irgendwann hat sie die million also ein
bisschen aufdruck natürlich und das ist
dann auch nach dreieinhalb jahre später
tatsächlich eingetroffen oder drei jahre
später ich weiß nicht genau und vor ein
paar tagen ist der eine million play
button hier eingetroffen
ich habe mich wirklich sehr gefreut ich
habe ein unboxing video gedreht das ist
nach meinem zweikanal blende ich euch
hier auch sehr gerne kurzen ausschnitt
ein wo mein gott leute endlich alter
jetzt da achtet nicht auf meine frisur
ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden wie
gesagt leute der welt zugestellt vom
absolut besten postboten ich bleibe euch
hier im bild ein grill hätte das auf
jeden fall ab ist ganz auf meine videos
verlinkt und abonniert auf jeden fall
auf den zwei kanal weil da kam jetzt
wirklich berlin video immer um 14 uhr
und wenn euch nicht über die geräusche
juli macht google ist nicht schlimm
kopf das jetzt so und natürlich dennoch
touristischer billionen euro bestehen
das hier ist der eine million play
waffen hier stets präsente to alex wie
vor kessing ron williams privat bin ich
wirklich stolz darauf sieht echt schön
aus der richtige platz ist noch nicht
gefunden aber es wird noch jetzt sei der
nicht verkauften jetzt für 5000 folge
nicht wird den scheiß ich würde ich
glaube wenn mir jemand da führt ich weiß
nicht ob ich ein verkauf würde wenn mir
jemand jetzt 30.000 euro dafür biete ich
glaube nicht würde ich glaube ich nicht
machen
auch wenn der an sich habe ich gehört
nun wert von 700 euro hat allerdings hat
jemand unter das video auf dem neuen
kanal also den projekten kanada
kommentiert jo alex stellen noch mal aus
spaß bei ebay ein
und ich fand das war eigentlich eine
gute idee und deswegen machen wir das
heute also ich stelle bei ebay
kleinanzeigen jetzt feiern wir haben
gerade am montag montagabend und das
video kommt wahrscheinlich morgen und
ich hoffe dass sich viele leute darauf
melden werden die irgendwas zu schreiben
werden und ich kann mir schon vorstellen
dass das ziemlich lustig werden kann
weil natürlich jetzt nicht jeder auf der
welt oder jeder in deutschland diesem
play button kennt aber das ist ja schon
ziemlich populär dass man als youtuber
mit einer million album play button
krieg zu deuten und deswegen würde ich
sagen wir machen jetzt mal kurz ein paar
fotos und dann stelle ich den bereits
700 euro verhandlungs basis okay das
hier ist das originale zertifikat legen
wir mal dazu
obwohl er erst mal fotografiere ich nur
den play button ok jetzt noch einmal mit
zertifikat und meinetwegen auch noch mit
der originalen verpackung also so ist
muss ich natürlich meinen namen darauf
unkenntlich machen weil es soll ja
keiner wissen um welchen ist mainz schon
wirklich so geboten sein dass leute das
ernst kaufen wollen
[Musik]
ja ich weiß nicht ob das so schloss ist
dass da nicht irgendwie ein bisschen zu
krass so ok ja vielleicht dass ich den
namen herbert okay so ich wünsche euch
hier sehr gerne mal kurz die fotos einem
die ich jetzt gleich hoch bleiben werde
sind wirklich sehr schön geworden
bereichert er glänzt ja so krassen das
sieht so geil aus er braucht auf jeden
fall noch eine bessere position als da
oben da sieht man dann ja gar nicht so
leute das hier ist mein ebay
kleinanzeigen account 100% übliche
antrat ich hab doch wirklich schon mal
was verkauft ich weiß nicht mehr was ich
hoffe der videos nicht gesperrt weil das
ist ja sozusagen nichts reales so ist ja
an sich nur krank als wenn ich ihn
wirklich verkaufen gut wenn mir jetzt
einer 50.000 euro bietet dann würde ich
den verkaufen weil man kann dennoch mal
nachgestellt moment dass wir gar nicht
mal so dumm dass ich da will ich jetzt
auch nicht ich will ja auch nicht da
ärger kriegen oder so aber es ist
möglich daher auch an vielen youtube
kanälen mehrere leute arbeiten die dann
halt eine million abonnenten erreichen
dass man dann auch mehrere als nur ein
play button bestellen kann also ich weiß
dass ich jetzt so einen zusätzlichen
bestellen könnte führt zum beispiel juri
der würde sein glaube ich so 700 euro
kosten
deswegen
man ist nicht ok egal anzeige aufgeben
kategorie ja was ist das an sicher
freizeit hobby ja denken was sind das
haben die für kategorien hier ja
handarbeit meinetwegen ok weiter versand
versand natürlich möglich ich biete eine
million eine million youtube youtube
play button gold beschreibung trophäe
für eine millionen youtube abonnenten
sachwert 700 euro preis mache ich
einfach mal 1000 euro verhandlungs basis
und ich würde sagen damit die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass es mehr
leute sehen und ich somit mehr
nachrichten bekommen die ich euch da
natürlich zeigen werde was die leute
dafür bieten würden
ich glaube halt wirklich dass niemand da
mehr als fordern euro verbietet aber wer
weiß nehmen wir hier einfach mal noch
dieses highlight dazu oder wiederholtes
suchmaschinen highlight reicht okay also
hier haben wir jetzt die anzeige gebucht
mit der heirat option und ich denke mal
dass wir absolut durch die decke gehen
kann wie schön das aussieht hier steht
jetzt sogar mein name drauf das heißt
die leute können das dann auch sehen mal
gucken was passiert ja leute natürlich
sagen ich geh jetzt gleich schlafen wir
sehen uns morgen früh wieder und ich bin
gespannt
leute was geht ab entschuldigung
folgende situation
ich bin heute morgen aufgewacht und habe
direkt erst mal eine nachricht von ebay
bekommen dass meine anzeige gesperrt
wurde weil irgendwer die nutzungsrechte
so als verletzt gesehen hat ich bin
solche gern ein irgendwie so war das da
dachte ich schon mal so eine scheiße
kann ich das video gar nicht machen aber
komischerweise wurde einige minuten
danach die anzeige online geschaltet und
ich habe jetzt mittlerweile wirklich
sehr viele nachrichten bekommen weswegen
ich das video doch machen kann ich habe
keine ahnung woran das liegt hier acht
und 24
eine anzeige wurde gelöscht da uns ein
rechteinhaber auf seiner anzeige
aufmerksam gemacht hat und seine rechte
durch deine anzeige verletzt sieht und
zwei minuten später wurde die anzeige
erfolgreich veröffentlicht aber erst
heute morgen
ich weiß nicht warum
keine ahnung wer jetzt gerade auch schon
14 uhr 30 und ich habe einige
nachrichten bekommen und auch viele
zuschauer auf diese anzeige generiert
ich weiß nicht ob das an dem 290 lage
und habe auch schon ein bisschen mit dem
geschrieben ich warte jetzt noch ein
bisschen ab und dann zeige ich euch mal
die ganzen stadt verläuft
weil die sind echt gut wie heute was
geht ab jetzt sitze ich wieder hier
wir haben jetzt zähle nach vier schon
ich habe die erste nachricht auch erst
um 13 uhr bekommen eben ein bisschen
komisch liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil
die meisten arbeiten oder in der schule
sind und ich habe jetzt aber doch dann
wirklich einige nachrichten gekriegt
auch ganz lustig es ist wirklich lustig
geworden und ich habe auch ein krasses
gebot bekommen
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal
an ich lese ich das vor und wir steigern
und ich kann dir natürlich die nachnamen
von den personen aber vorher kann ich da
drin lassen stammt zum beispiel hat mir
geschrieben um 14.40 alter bist du der
echte alex wie von youtube hab deine
adresse des screen shot xd
wahrscheinlich ist tom auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen jünger ich hätte sogar
fast meine richtige adresse angegeben
ich habe es noch geändert ist mir dann
ein gefallen
mein nam habe ich auch ein bisschen
verkürzt blöd nur dass es nicht meine
echte ist hat er geschrieben habe schon
in meiner klassen gruppe geschickt
schade
der garten muss was ist los mit dir also
tun wenn ich nicht mehr auf der straße
sehe dann ziehe ich mir die ohren kannst
mir glauben ich habe übrigens 223
ansichten auf den play button ist gar
nicht mal so schlecht für die kurze zeit
oder kommen wir zum nächsten verlauf der
ist von ja ich kann sie einen guten
namen halo wie sie verkaufst du den play
button
gute frage brauche ihn nicht also ich
habe überlegt was ich schreiben soll er
hin schrieben okay dass ich würde so
etwas niemals verkaufen wenn ich eine
mio auf youtube hätte ich geschrieben
wieso nicht ja aber das eine wichtige
auszeichnung für ein ist eine mio
abonnenten schafft nicht jeder bereits
auf der überhaupt alex wie bist habe ich
gefragt willst du denn kaufen wenn du
mir vergewissern dass du auch alex wie
bist ich überlege gerade dann wollte ihm
eigentlich ein foto schicken habe ich
dann aber mir was anderes überlegt
und so habe ich geschrieben habe den
play button bei ihm aus der wohnung
geklaut
aber er weiß ist denke noch nicht wird
er nicht sagen das war vielleicht ein
bisschen zu dummen also das zeigt
vermutlich jeder und dann hat er ja
genau ich bin der kaiser von china
ok dann kommen jetzt aber zu den geboten
aber es hat geschrieben ist das
originale suche für meinen sohn zum
geburtstag 3000 euro will ich bieten ich
habe das direkt gelesen und ich dachte
so alter wald folgen ich habe 1000 euro
verhandlungstages angegeben dann hab ich
geschrieben ja genau der wäre schon
original halt mit meinem namen drauf
3000 euro zehn minuten später hat er
geschrieben 300 euro entschuldigt bitte
dann habe ich geschrieben nein das wäre
mir deutlich zu wenig 1000 euro wäre
schon angebracht dafür ist das sind
original gold das hat meine mutter hat
übrigens auch gefragt ob das original
gold ist und ich fiel der wert ist habe
ich ihr gesagt ist natürlich nicht
original
ich glaube das ist so ja ich weiß nicht
ob das vielleicht so eine art blattgold
ist ich kenne mich damit jetzt auch
nicht aus ich habe ihm geschrieben ein
glaube nur so blattgold umzogen weg zur
zwei kilo das teil auch so weil er noch
gefragt hat wie schwer ist das und
seitdem habe ich leider keine antwort
mehr von ihm bekommen ich denke sein
interesse ist verschwunden
einer habe ich noch und zwar von
sebastian er hat geschrieben bist du
blöd wieso verkaufst du den vollen dank
war mal wieder aber bin ich ja nicht
anders gewohnt musste 100.000 play
button also der schlinge könnt nicht
dann habe ich geschrieben was würdest du
denn bieten dann hat er geschrieben
würde 600 euro bieten falls er wirklich
original ist liebe grüße hab ich
geschrieben 900 euro hat er geschrieben
nur verarscht doch oder als wenn du
wirklich verkaufs kann nicht mehr geben
als 600 also eine antwort darauf wie
viele leute dafür geben würden hätte ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als 600
euro keine ahnung vielleicht findet sich
noch ein dummer der dafür
aber das ding ist ja auch das ist eine
personalisierte auszeichnung die für die
leute die dann bekommen wahrscheinlich
also für mich hat das einen viel höheren
wert als tausend euro so und ich würde
jetzt auch niemals auf die idee
kommenden play button von einem anderen
zu kaufen so das macht ihr eigentlich
keinen sinn weil an sich der wert von
den dingen ist wohl so 700 euro habe ja
schon oft genug ist trotzdem war es ganz
interessant ich nehme die anzahl jetzt
raus ich habe jetzt zwar nicht die
heftigsten geburt zu bekommen
ich hoffe ja du trotzdem spaß beim
anschauen abonniert auf jeden fall
meinen zweiten kanal und wir sehen uns
demnächst wieder daumen nach oben geben
abonniert auch den kanada gerne zu